Kanye West drops a big accusation
against Drake saying the rapper has been
threatening his family the ongoing feud
between the rappers is getting ugly you
guys on Twitter because of course it's
Kanye and yes Kim K is involved let's
break this all down it started when
Kanye hit up Twitter to accuse Drake of
avoiding him and taking some underhanded
shots at him never go to Twitter guys
Kanye also tweeted that he never told
rapper Pusha T about Drake's son Adonis
who Pusha T exposed in his district the
story of added on the babies involved is
deeper than breath we talking character
let me keep with the facts
you are hiding a child that that boy
come home he tweeted quote I would never
intentionally try to hurt you bro I
never even heard none of the diss
records then Kanye claimed that Drake
sent him purple demon emojis while he
was going through a mental breakdown
following his now infamous TMZ live
appearance quote sending purple emojis
when I'm dealing with mental Shh I need
my apologies now alright so then
everything seems to be calming down when
J updated the internet revealing that
he'd finally gotten a phone call from
the rapper but um apparently not Kanye
then went on to accuse Drake of well
Walters let his words speak for
themselves
quote Drake called trying to threaten me
so Drake if anything happens to me or
anyone from my family you are the first
suspect adding you pick on people with
mental health issues
yikes this is so ugly dramatic right
well it did not end there this is when
Kanye's wife Kim got in on the oh so
public feud tweeting quote never
threatened my husband or our family he
paved the way for there to be a Drake
she also added this my husband is the
most brilliant person the most genius
person that I know he has broken so many
boundaries everything from music stage
design fashion and culture and will
continue to change the world obviously
there's a lot of history here this whole
thing really got started months ago in
September Kanye took to Instagram
slam Drake regarding rumors said he had
an affair with Kim which of course she
quickly shut down Kanye later apologized
to Drake writing on Twitter quote
sending good energy and love to Drake I
understand where the confusion started
as of right now Drake has not responded
to the recent outburst except he did
post these laughing/crying emojis on his
instace Tori which is just you know an
emoji says a thousand words but for what
it's worth Miley Cyrus and Ariana Grande
just want everyone to get along and
listen to their new music Ari released
her single imagine and Miley released
happy Christmas war is over ariana
tweeted quote guys I know there are
grown men arguing online right now but
Miley and I dropping our beautiful new
songs tonight so if y'all could please
just behave for just like a few hours so
that girls can shine that'd be so sick
thank you Miley chimed in writing didn't
they hear the news war is over Thank You
next now that's what I call a mic drop
until next time I'm at Halle underscore
Stephens